The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation or to
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR STRANG:
[INAUDIBLE] Professor Suvrit
Sra from EECS who taught 6.036
and the graduate version.
And maybe some of you had him in
one or other of those classes.
So he graciously
agreed to come today
and to talk about Stochastic
Gradient Descent, SGD.
And it's terrific.
Yeah, yeah.
So we're not quite
at 1:05, but close.
If everything is
ready, then we're off.
OK.
Good.
PROFESSOR SRA: And your
cutoff is like 1:55?
PROFESSOR STRANG: Yeah.
PROFESSOR SRA: OK.
PROFESSOR STRANG: But this
is not a sharp cutoff.
PROFESSOR SRA: Why is there
[INAUDIBLE] fluctuation?
PROFESSOR STRANG: There you go.
PROFESSOR SRA: Somebody changed
their resolution it seems,
but that's fine.
It doesn't bother us.
So I'm going to tell you about,
let's say, one of the most
ancient optimization
methods, much
simpler than, in fact,
the more advanced methods
you have already seen in class.
And interestingly, this
more ancient method
remains "the" method for
training large scale machine
learning systems.
So there's a little bit
of history around that.
I'm not going to go too
much into the history.
But the bottom line,
which probably Gil
has also mentioned
to you in class,
that at least four large data
science problems, in the end,
stuff reduces to solving
an optimization problem.
And in current times these
optimization problems
are pretty large.
So people actually
started liking stuff
like gradient descent, which
was invented by Cauchy back
in the day.
And this is how I'm writing
the abstract problem.
And what I want to see is--
OK, is it fitting on the page?
This is my implementation in
MATLAB of gradient descent,
just to set the stage that
this stuff really looks simple.
You've already seen
gradient descent.
And today, essentially,
in a nutshell,
what really changes
in this implementation
of gradient descent
is this part.
That's it.
So you've seen gradient descent.
I'm only going to
change this one line.
And the change of that
one line, surprisingly,
is driving all the deep
learning tool boxes
and all of large scale
machine learning, et cetera.
This is an oversimplification,
but morally, that's it.
So let's look at
what's happening.
So I will become very
concrete pretty soon.
But abstractly, what
I want you to look at
is the kinds of
optimization problems
we are solving in
machine learning.
And I'll give you very concrete
examples of these optimization
problems so that you can
relate to them better.
But I'm just writing
this as the key topic,
that all the
optimization problems
that I'm going to talk about
today, they look like that.
You're trying to
find an x over a cost
function, where the
cost function can
be written as a sum.
In modern day machine
learning parlance
these are also called
finite sum problems,
in case you run into that term.
And they just call it finite
because n is finite here.
In pure optimization
theory parlance,
n can actually go to infinity.
And then they're called
stochastic optimization
problems--
just for terminology, if
while searching the internet
you run into some
such terminology
so you kind of
know what it means.
So here is our setup
in machine learning.
We have a bunch
of training data.
On this slide, I'm
calling x1 through xn.
These are the training
data, the raw features.
Later, actually, I'll
stop writing x for them
and write them
with the letter a.
But hopefully, that's OK.
So x1 through xn, these could be
just raw images, for instance,
in ImageNet or some
other image data set.
They could be text documents.
They could be anything.
y1 through yn, in
classical machine learning,
think of them as
plus minus 1 labels--
cat, not cat-- or
in a regression
setup as some real number.
So that's our training data.
We have d dimensional
raw vectors, n of those.
And we have corresponding
labels which
can be either plus or minus
1 in a classification setting
or a real number in
a regression setting.
It's kind of immaterial
for my lecture right now.
So that's the input.
And whenever anybody says
large scale machine learning,
what do we really mean?
What we mean is that both
n and d can be large.
So what does that mean in words?
That n is the number of
training data points.
So n could be, these days, what?
A million, 10
million, 100 million,
depends on how big computers
and data sets you've got.
So n can be huge.
d, the dimensionality,
the vectors
that we are working with--
the raw vectors-- that
can also be pretty large.
Think of x is an image.
If it's a megapixel image, wow,
d's like a million already.
If you are somebody like
Criteo or Facebook or Google,
and your serving web
advertisements, d--
these are the features--
could be like in several
hundred million, even
a billion, where they encode
all sorts of nasty stuff
and information they
collect about you as users.
So many nasty things
they can collect, right?
So d and n are huge.
And it's because both
d and n are huge,
we are interested in
thinking of optimization
methods for large scale
machine learning that can
handle such big d and n.
And this is driving
a lot of research
on some theoretical
computer science, including
the search for sublinear
time algorithms
and all sorts of data structures
and hashing tricks just
to deal with these
two quantities.
So here is an example--
super toy example.
And I hope really
that I can squeeze
in a little bit of proof
later on towards the end.
I'll take a vote here in class
to see if you are interested.
Let's look at the
most classic question,
least squares regression.
A is a matrix of observations--
or sorry, measurements. b
are the observations.
You're trying to solve
Ax minus b whole square.
Of course, a linear
system of equations,
the most classical
problem in linear algebra,
can also be written
like that, let's say.
This can be expanded.
Hopefully, you are
comfortable with this norm.
So x2 squared, this
is just defined
as that's the definition
of that notation.
But I'll just write
it only once now.
I hope you are fully
familiar with that.
So by expanding that, I managed
to write least squares problem
in terms of what I call
the finite sum right.
So it's just going over
all the roles in a.
The end roles, let's say.
So that's the classical
least squares problem.
It assumes this finite sum
form that we care about.
Another random example is
something called Lasso.
Maybe if anybody of you has
played with machine learning
or statistics
toolkits, you may have
seen something called Lasso.
Lasso is essentially
least squares,
but there's another
simple term at the end.
That again, looks like f of i.
Support vector machines,
once a workhorse of--
there's still a
workhorse horse of people
who work with small
to medium sized data.
Deep learning stuff requires
huge amount of data.
If you have small to
medium amount of data,
logistic regression support,
vector machines, trees, et
cetera, this will be
your first go to methods.
They are still very widely used.
These problems are,
again, written in terms
of a loss over training data.
So this again, has this
awesome format, which
I'll just now record here.
I may not even
need to repeat it.
Sometimes I write it
with a normalization--
you may wonder at
some point, why--
as that finite sum problem.
And maybe the example
that you wanted to see
is something like that.
So deep neural networks that
are very popular these days,
they are just yet
another example
of this finite sum problem.
How are they an example of that?
So you have n
training data points,
there's a neural network
loss, like cross entropy,
or what have you, squared
loss, cross-- any kind of loss.
yi's are the labels--
cat not cat, or
maybe a multiclass.
And then you have
a transfer function
called a deep neural network
which takes raw images as input
and generates a prediction
whether this is a dog or not.
That whole thing I'm
just calling DNN.
So it's a function of ai's
which are the training data.
X are the [INAUDIBLE] matrices
of the neural network,
so I've just compressed
the whole neural network
into this notation.
Once again, it's nothing but
an instance of that finite sum.
So that fi in there captures
the entire neural network
architecture.
But mathematically, it's still
just one particular instance
of this finite sum problem.
And then people who do a lot of
statistics, maximum likelihood
estimation.
This is log likelihood
over n observations.
You want to maximize
log likelihood.
Once again, just a finite sum.
So pretty much most
of the problems
that we're interested in
machine learning and statistics,
when I write them down as
an optimization problem,
they look like these
finite sum problems.
And that's the reason to
develop specialized optimization
procedures to solve such
finite some problems.
And that's where SGD comes in.
OK.
So that's kind of
just the backdrop.
Let's look at now how to go
about solving these problems.
So hopefully this iteration
is familiar to you--
gradient descent, right?
OK.
So just for notation,
f of x refers
to that entire summation.
F sub i of x refers
to a single component.
So if you were to try to solve--
that is, to minimize this cost
function, neural network, SVM,
what have you using
gradient descent,
that's what one iteration
would look like.
Because it's a finite sum,
gradients are linear operators.
Gradient of the sum is
the sum of the gradient--
that's gradient descent for you.
And now, I'll just ask
a rhetoric question
that, if you put yourself
in the shoes of you're
[INAUDIBLE] algorithm
designers, some things that you
may want to think
about-- what may you
not like about this iteration,
given that big n, big d story
that I told you?
So anybody have any
reservations or about
drawbacks of this iteration?
Any comments?
AUDIENCE: It's a pretty big sum.
PROFESSOR SRA: It's
a pretty big sum.
Especially if n
is say, a billion
on some bigger,
[INAUDIBLE] number.
That is definitely
a big drawback.
Because that is the prime
drawback for large scale,
that n be huge.
There can be variety
of other drawbacks.
Some of those you may
have seen previously
when people compare whether to
the gradient or to do Newton,
et.
Cetera but for the purpose
of today, for finite sums,
the big drawback is computing
gradient at a single point--
there's a subscript
xk missing there--
involves computing the
gradient of that entire sum.
That sum is some is huge.
So getting a single
gradient to do
a single step of gradient
descent for a large data set
could take you hours or days.
So that's a major drawback.
But then if you
identify that drawback,
anybody have any
ideas how to counter
that drawback, at least, say,
purely from an engineering
perspective?
I heard something.
Can you speak up?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR SRA: Using
some kind of badge?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
PROFESSOR SRA: You are
well ahead of my slides.
We are coming to that.
And maybe somebody else has,
essentially, the same idea.
Anybody want to suggest how
to circumvent that big n
stuff in there?
Anything-- suppose you
are implementing this.
What would you do?
AUDIENCE: One example at a time.
PROFESSOR SRA: One
example at a time.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] a
random sample full set of n.
PROFESSOR SRA: Random
sample of the full n.
So these are all
excellent ideas.
And hence, you
folks in the class
have discovered the
most important method
for optimizing machine
learning problems,
sitting here in a few moments.
Isn't that great?
So the part that is missing
is of course to make sense of,
does this idea work?
Why does it work?
So this idea is really at the
heart of stochastic gradient
descent.
So let's see.
Maybe I can show you an
example, actually, that I--
I'll show you a simulation I
found on somebody's nice web
page about that.
So exactly your idea, just
put in slight mathematical
notation, that what
if at each iteration,
we randomly pick some integer,
i k out of the n training data
points, and we instead
just perform this update.
So instead of using
the full gradient,
you just compute the gradient
of a single randomly chosen data
point.
So what have you done with that?
One iteration is
now n times faster.
If n were a million or a
billion wow, that's super fast.
But why should this work right?
I could have done
many other things.
I could have not done any update
and just output the 0 vector.
That would take even less time.
That's also an idea.
It's a bad idea, but it's
an idea in a similar league.
I could have done a
variety of other things.
Why would you think that just
replacing that sum with just
one random example may work?
Let's see a little
bit more about that.
So of course, it's
n times faster,
and the key question
for us here, right now--
the scientific question--
is does this make sense?
It makes great
engineering sense.
Does it make algorithmic
or mathematical sense?
So this idea of doing stuff
in the stochastic manner
was actually originally
proposed by Robbins and Monro,
somewhere, I think, around 1951.
And that's the most
advanced method
that we are essentially
using currently.
So I'll show you that
this idea makes sense.
But maybe let's first just
look at a comparison of SGD
with gradient descent in
this guy's simulation.
So this is that MATLAB
code of gradient descent,
and this is just a simulation
of gradient descent.
As you pick a different step
size, that gamma in there,
you move towards the optimum.
If the step size is small,
you make many small steps,
and you keep making slow
progress, and you reach there.
That's for a
well-conditioned problem
and an ill-conditioned problem.
It takes you even larger.
In a neural network type
problem which is nonconvex,
you have to typically work
with smaller step sizes.
And if you take bigger ones,
you can get crazy oscillations.
But that's gradient descent.
In comparison, let's hope
that this loads correctly.
Well, there's even a
picture of Robbins,
who was a co-discoverer of the
stochastic gradient method.
There's a nice
simulation, that instead
of making that kind of
deterministic descent--
after all, gradient descent
is called "gradient descent."
At every step it descends-- it
decreases the cost function.
Stochastic gradient descent
is actually a misnomer.
At every step it
doesn't do any descent.
It does not decrease
the cost function.
So you see, at every step, those
are the contours of the cost
function.
Sometimes it goes up,
sometimes it goes down.
It fluctuates around, but it
kind of stochastically still
seems to be making progress
towards the optimum.
And stochastic gradient
descent, because it's not
using exact gradients,
just working
with these random
examples, it actually
is much more sensitive
to step sizes.
And you can see, as I increase
the step size, its behavior.
This is actually full simulation
for [INAUDIBLE] problem.
So initially, what I
want you to notice is--
let me go through
this a few times--
keep looking at what patterns
you may notice in how
that line is fluctuating.
Hopefully this is big
enough for everybody to see.
So this slider that I'm
shifting is just the step size.
So let me just remind you, in
case you forgot, the iteration.
We are running x k plus 1
is x k minus some eta k--
It's called alpha there--
times some randomly
chosen data point.
You compute its gradient.
This is SGD.
That's what we are running.
And we threw away
tons of information.
We didn't use the full gradient.
We're just using
this crude gradient.
So this process
is very sensitive
to the other parameter in the
system, which is the step size.
Much more sensitive than
gradient descent, in fact.
And let's see.
As I vary the step
size, see if you
can notice some
patterns on how it
tries to go towards an optimum.
There's a zoomed in version,
also, of this later, here.
I'll come to that shortly.
I'll repeat again, and then I'll
ask you for your observations--
if you notice some patterns.
I don't know if they're
necessarily apparent.
That's the thing with patterns.
Because I know the answer,
so I see the pattern.
If you don't know the
answer, you may or may not
see the pattern.
But I want to see if you
actually see the pattern as I
change the step size.
So maybe that was
enough simulation.
Anybody have any comments
on what kind of pattern
you may have observed?
Yep.
AUDIENCE: It seems like the
clustering in the middle
is getting larger
and more widespread.
PROFESSOR SRA: Yeah, definitely.
That's a great observation.
Any other comments?
There's one more interesting
thing happening here,
which is a very, very
typical thing for SGD,
and one of the reasons
why people love SGD.
Let me do that
once again briefly.
OK, this is tiny step size--
almost zero.
Close to zero-- it's
not exactly zero.
So you see what happens
for a very tiny step size?
It doesn't look that
stochastic, right?
But that's kind of obvious from
there if eta k is very tiny,
you'll hardly make any move.
So things will look very stable.
And in fact, the speed at which
stochastic gradient converges,
that's extremely sensitive to
how you pick the step size.
It's still an open
research problem
to come up with the best
way to pick step sizes.
So it's even that simple, it
doesn't mean it's trivial.
And as I vary the step
size, it make some progress,
and it goes towards
the solution.
Are you now beginning
to see that it
seems to be making a more stable
progress in the beginning?
And when it comes
close to the solution,
it's fluctuating more.
And the bigger the
step size, the amount
of fluctuation near
the solution is wilder
as he noticed back there.
But one very interesting thing
is more or less constant.
There is more fluctuation
also on the outside,
but you see that the
initial part still
seems to be making
pretty good progress.
And as you come close to the
solution, it fluctuates more.
And that is a very
principally typical behavior
of stochastic gradient
descent, that in the beginning,
it makes rapid strides.
So you may see
your training loss
decrease super fast and
then kind of peter out.
And it's this
particular behavior
which guard people
super excited,
that, hey, in machine
learning, we are working
with all sorts of big data.
I just want a quick and dirty
progress on my training.
I don't care about getting
to the best optimum.
Because in machine
learning, you don't just
care about solving the
optimization problem,
you actually care
about finding solutions
that work well on unseen data.
So that means you don't
want to over fit and solve
the optimization
problem supremely well.
So it's great to make
rapid initial progress.
And if after that progress
peters out, it's OK.
This intuitionistic
statement that I'm making,
in some nice cases like
convex optimization problems,
one can mathematically
fully quantify these.
One can prove theorems
to quantify each thing
that I said in terms of how
close, how fast, and so on.
We'll see a little bit of that.
And this is what
really happens to SGD.
It makes great initial
progress, and regardless
of how you use step sizes,
close to the optimum
it can either get
stuck, or enter
some kind of chaos dynamics,
or just behave like crazy.
So that's typical of SGD.
And let's look at now
slight mathematical insight
into roughly why this
behavior may happen.
This is a trivial,
one-dimensional optimization
problem, but it
conveys the crux of why
this behavior is displayed by
stochastic gradient methods.
That it works really
well in the beginning,
and then, God knows
what happens when
it comes close to the
optimum, anything can happen.
So let's look at that.
OK.
So let's look at a simple,
one-dimensional optimization
problem.
I'll kind of draw it out
maybe on the other side
so that people on this
side are not disadvantaged.
So I'll just draw out at
least squares problem--
x is one dimensional.
Previously, I had ai transpose
x Now, ai is also a scalar.
So it's just 1D stuff--
everything is 1D
So this is our setup.
Think of ai into x minus b i.
These are quadratic functions,
so they look like this.
Corresponding to
different eyes, there's
like some different
functions sitting and so on.
So these are my n
different loss functions,
and I want to minimize those.
We know-- we can actually
explicitly compute
the solution of that problem.
So you set the derivative
of f of x to 0 so.
You set the gradient
of f of x to 0.
Hopefully, that's
easy for you to do.
So if you do that
differentiation,
will get gradient of f
of x will just given by.
Well, you can do
that in your head,
I'll just write it
out explicitly. aix
minus bi times ai Is equal to
zero, and you solve that for x.
You get x star, the optimum
of this least squares problem.
So we actually know how
to solve it pretty easily.
That's a really cool
example actually.
I got that from textbook by
Professor Dimitry [INAUDIBLE]..
Now, a very interesting thing.
We are not going to
use the full gradient,
we are only going
to use the gradients
of individual components.
So what does the minimum of an
individual component look like?
Well, the minimum of
an individual component
is attained when we can
set this thing to 0.
And that thing becomes 0 if
we just pick x equal to bi
divided by ai, right?
So a single component can
be minimized by that choice.
So you can do a little
bit of arithmetic
mean, geometric mean
type inequalities
to draw this picture.
So over all i from
1 through n, this
is the minimum value of
this ratio, ai by bi.
And let's say this is the
max value of ai by bi.
And we know that closed
form solution, that
is the true solution.
So you can verify
with some algebra
that that solution will
lie in this interval.
So you may want to--
this is a tiny exercise for you.
Hopefully some of you
love inequalities like me.
So this is hopefully
not such a bad exercise.
But you can verify
that within this range
of the individual
mins and max is where
the combined solution lies.
So of course, intuitively,
with a physics styles thinking,
you would have guessed
that right away.
That means when
you're outside where
the individual solutions, let's
call this the far out zone.
And also, this side
is the far out zone.
And this region, within which
the true minimum can lie,
you can say, OK, that's
the region of confusion.
Why I'm calling it the
region of confusion?
Because there, by
minimizing an individual fi,
you're not going
to be able to tell
what is the combined x star.
That's all.
And a very interesting
thing happens now, just
to gain some mathematical
insight into that simulation
that I showed you, that if
you have a scalar x that
is outside this region of
confusion, which states
that if you're far
from the region
within which an optimum can lie.
So you're far away.
So you've just started
out your progress,
you made a random
initialization, most likely
far away from where
the solution is.
So suppose that's where you are.
What happens when you're
in that far out region?
So if you're in
the far out region,
you use a stochastic gradient
of some i-th component.
So the full gradient
will look like that.
A stochastic gradient looks
like just one component.
And when you're far out,
outside that min and max regime,
then you can check by
just looking at it,
that a stochastic gradient,
in the far away regime,
has exactly the same sign
as the full gradient.
What does gradient descent do?
It says, well, walk
in the direction
of the negative gradient.
And far away from the
optimum, outside the region
of confusion, you're stochastic
gradient has the same sign
as the true gradient.
Maybe in more linear
algebra terms,
it makes an acute angle
with your gradient.
So that means if even though
a stochastic gradient is not
exactly the full
gradient, it has
some component in the
direction of the true gradient.
This is one 1D.
Here it is, exactly
the same sign.
In multiple dimensions,
this is the idea
that it'll have some
component in the direction
of true gradient
when you're far away.
Which means, if you then
use that direction to make
an update in that
style, you will end up
making solid progress.
And the beauty
is, in the time it
would have taken you to do
one single iteration of batch
gradient descent, far
away you can do millions
stochastic steps, and, each
step will make some progress.
And that's where we see
this dramatic, initial--
again, in the 1D case this
is explicit mathematically.
In the high-D case,
this is more intuitive.
Without further assumptions
about angles, et,
we can't make such
a broad claim.
But intuitively, this
is what's happening,
and why you see this
awesome initial speed.
And once you're inside
the region of confusion,
then this behavior breaks down.
Some stochastic
gradient may have
the same sign as the full
gradient, some may not.
And that's why you can
get crazy fluctuations.
So this simple 1D
example kind of exactly
shows you what we
saw in that picture.
And people really love
this initial progress.
Because, often we also
do early stopping.
You train for some time, and
then you say, OK, I'm done.
So importantly, if you are
purely an optimization person,
not thinking so much in
terms of machine learning,
then please keep in mind that
stochastic gradient descent
or stochastic gradient method
is not such a great optimization
method.
Because once in the
region of confusion,
it can just fluctuate
all over forever.
And in machine learning,
you say, oh, the region
of confusion, that's fine.
It'll make my method robust.
It'll make my neural network
training more robust.
It's generalize
better, et cetera,
er cetera-- we like that.
So it depends on which
frame of mind you're in.
So that's the awesome thing
about the stochastic gradient
method.
So I'll give you now
key mathematical ideas
behind the success of SGD.
This was like
little illustration.
Very abstractly, this is
an idea that [INAUDIBLE]
throughout machine learning and
throughout theoretical computer
science and statistics, anytime
you're faced with the need
to compute an
expensive quantity,
resort to randomization to
speed up the computation.
SGD is one example.
The true gradient was
expensive to compute,
so we create a randomized
estimate of the true gradient.
And the randomized estimate
is much faster to compute.
And mathematically, what
will start happening is,
depending on how good your
randomized estimate is,
your method may or may not
convert to the right answer.
So of course, one has
to be careful about what
particular randomized
estimate one makes.
But really abstractly,
even if I hadn't
shown you, the main
idea, this idea
you can apply in
many other settings.
If you have a
difficult quantity,
come up with a
randomized estimate
and save on computation.
This is a very important theme
throughout machine learning
and data science.
And this is the key property.
So stochastic gradient descent,
it uses stochastic gradients.
Stochastic is, here,
used very loosely.
And it just means that
some randomization.
That's all it means.
And the property-- the
key property that we have
is in expectation.
The expectation is over
whatever randomness you used.
So if you picked some random
training data point out
of the million,
then the expectation
is over the probability
distribution
over what kind of
randomness you used.
If you picked uniformly at
random from a million points,
then this expectation is over
that uniform probability.
But the key property for
SGD, or at least the version
of SGD I'm talking about, is
that that over that randomness.
The thing that you're
pretending to use,
instead of the true gradient
n expectation actually
it is the true gradient.
So in statistics
language, this is
called the stochastic
gradient that we
use is an unbiased estimate
of the true gradient.
And this is a very
important property
in the mathematical analysis
of stochastic gradient descent,
that it is an
unbiased estimate, And
Intuitively speaking
anytime you did any proof
in class, or in the book,
or lecture, or to wherever,
where you were using
true gradients,
more or less, you can
do those same proofs--
more or less, not always.
Using stochastic gradients
by encapsulating everything
within expectations
over the randomness.
I'll show you an example
of what I mean by that.
I'm just trying to
simplify that for you.
And
In particular, the
unbiasedness is great.
So it means I can
kind of plug-in
these stochastic gradients in
place of the true gradient,
and I'm still doing
something meaningful.
So this is answering
that earlier question,
why this random stuff?
Why should we think it may work?
But there's another
very important aspect
to why it works, beyond
this unbiasedness,
that the amount of noise, or
the amount of stochasticity
is controlled.
So just because it is
an unbiased estimate,
doesn't mean that it's
going to work that well.
Why?
Because it could still
fluctuate hugely, right?
Essentially, plus infinity
here, minus infinity here.
You take an average, you get 0.
So that is essentially
unbiased, but the fluctuation
is gigantic.
So whenever talking
about estimates,
what's the other key quantity
we need to care about
beyond expectation?
AUDIENCE: Variance.
PROFESSOR SRA: Variance.
And really, the key
thing that governs
the speed at which stochastic
gradient descent does
the job that we want it to
do is, how much variance do
the stochastic gradients have?
Just this simple
statistical point, in fact,
is at the heart of a
sequence of research progress
in the past five years in the
field of stochastic gradient,
where people have worked
really hard to come up
with newer and newer,
fancier and fancier
versions of stochastic
gradient which
have the unbiasedness
property, but have
smaller and smaller variance.
And the smaller the
variance you have,
the better your
stochastic gradient
is as a replacement
of the true gradient.
And of course, the
better [INAUDIBLE]
of the true gradient, then
you truly get that n times up.
So the speed of
convergence depends
on how noisy the
stochastic gradients are.
It seems like I'm
going too slow.
I won't be able to do
a proof, which sucks.
But let me actually tell
you then about, rather than
the proof, I think I'll
share the proof with Gil.
Because the proof that I
wanted to actually show you,
gives a proof of
stochastic gradient
is well-behaved on both
convex and nonconvex problems.
And the proof I
wanted to show was
for the nonconvex case, because
it applies to neural networks.
So you may be curious
about that proof.
And remarkably, that
proof is much simpler
than the case of
convex problems.
So let me just mention
some very important points
about stochastic gradient.
So even though this method
has been around since 1951,
every deep learning
tool kit has it,
and we are studying it
in class, there are still
gaps between what we
can say theoretically
and what happens in practice.
And I'll show you
those gaps already,
and encourage you to think
about those if you wish.
So let's look back
at our problem
and deliver two variants.
So here are the two variants.
I'm going to ask
if any of you is
familiar with these variants
in some way or the other.
So I just call it feasible.
Here, there are no constraints.
So start with any random
vector of your choice.
In deep network training
you have to work harder.
And then, this is the
iteration you run--
option 1 and option 2.
So option 1 says, that was
the idea we had in class,
randomly pick some
training data point,
use its stochastic gradient.
What do we mean
by randomly pick?
The moment you use
the word random,
you have to define
what's the randomness.
So one randomness is
uniform probability
over n training data points.
That is one randomness.
The other version is you
pick a training data point
without replacement.
So with replacement means
uniformly at random.
Each time you draw a
number from 1 through n,
use their stochastic
gradient, move on.
Which means the same point can
easily be picked twice, also.
And without replacement means,
if you've picked a point number
three, you're not
going to pick it again
until you've gone through
the entire training data set.
Those are two types
of randomness.
Which version would you use?
There is no right or
wrong answer to this.
I'm just taking a poll.
What would you use?
Think that you're writing
a program for this,
and maybe think really
pragmatically, practically.
So that's enough of a hint.
Which one would you use--
I'm just curious.
Who would use 1?
Please, raise hands.
OK.
And the exclusion--
the compliment thereof.
I don't know.
Maybe some people are undecided.
Who would use 2?
Very few people.
Ooh, OK.
How many of you use
neural network training
toolkits like TensorFlow,
PyTorch, whatnot?
Which version are they using?
Actually, every person in the
real world is using version 2.
Are you really going to
randomly go through your RAM
each time to pick random points?
That'll kill your GPU
performance like anything.
What people do is
take a data set,
use a pre-shuffle operation,
and then just stream
through the data.
What does streaming
through the data mean?
Without replacement.
So all the toolkits
actually are using the
without replacement version,
even though, intuitively,
uniform random feels much nicer.
And that feeling
is not ill-founded,
because that's the
only version we know
how to analyze mathematically.
So even for this method,
everybody studies it.
There are a million
papers on it.
The version that
is used in practice
is not the version we
know how to analyze.
It's a major open problem in
the field of stochastic gradient
to actually analyze the version
that we use in practice.
It's kind of embarrassing,
but without replacement means
non-IAD probability theory,
and non-IAD probability theory
is not so easy.
That's the answer.
OK.
So the other version is
this mini-batch idea--
which you mentioned
really early on--
is that rather than
pick one random point,
I'll pick a mini batch.
So I had a million points--
each time, instead of picking
one, maybe I'll pick 10, or.
100, or 1,000, or what have you.
So this averages things.
Averaging things
reduces the variance.
So this is actually
a good thing,
because the more
quantities you average,
the less noise you have.
That's kind of what
happened in probability.
So we pick a mini-batch, and
the stochastic estimate now
is this not just
a single gradient,
but averaged over a mini-batch.
So a mini-batch of size 1
is the pure vanilla SGD.
Mini-batch of size n is nothing
other than pure gradient
descent.
Something in between is
what people actually use.
And again, the
theoretical analysis
only exists if the mini-batch
is picked with replacement
not without replacement.
So one of the reasons actually--
a very important thing--
in theory, you don't
gain too much in terms
of computational gains
on convergent speed
by using mini-batches.
But mini-batches are
really crucial, especially
in the deep learning,
GPU-style training,
because they allow you
to do things in parallel.
Each thread or each core
or subcore or small chip
or what have, you
depending on your hardware,
can be working with one
stochastic gradient.
So mini-batches, the larger
the mini batch the more things
you can do in parallel.
So mini-batches are
greatly exploited by people
to give you a cheap
version of parallelism.
And where does the
parallelism happen?
You can think that each core
computes a stochastic gradient.
So the hard part is not
adding these things up
and making the update to x,
the hard part is computing
a stochastic gradient.
So if you can compute
10,000 of those in parallel
because you have 10,000
cores, great for you.
And that's the reason people
love using mini-batches.
But a nice side
remark here, this also
brings us closer to the
research edge of things again.
That, well, you'd love to
use very large mini-batches
so that you can fully max
out on the parallelism
available to you.
Maybe you have a
multi-GPU system,
if you're friends
with nVidia or Google.
I only have two GPUs.
But it depends on how
many GPU shows you have.
You'd like to really
max out on parallelism
so that you can really
crunch through big data sets
as fast as possible.
But you know what happens
with very large mini-batches?
So if you have very
large mini-batches,
stochastic gradient
starts looking more like?
Full gradient
descent, which is also
called batch gradient descent.
That's not a bad thing.
That's awesome for optimization.
But it is a weird conundrum
that happens in training
deep neural networks.
This type of problem we wouldn't
have for convex optimization.
But in deep neural
networks, this
is really disturbing
thing happens,
that if you use this
very large mini-batches,
your method starts
resembling gradient descent.
That means it decreases
noise so much so
that this region of
confusion shrinks so much--
which all sounds
good, but it ends up
being really bad for
machine learning.
That's what I said,
that in machine learning
you want some region
of uncertainty.
And what it means actually
is, a lot of people
have been working on this,
including at big companies,
that if you reduce that region
of uncertainty too much,
you end up over-fitting
your neural network.
And then it starts sucking
in its test data, unseen data
performance.
So even though for parallelism,
programming, optimization
theory, big
mini-batch is awesome,
unfortunately there's price
to be paid, that it hurts
your test error performance.
And there are all
sorts of methods
people are trying to cook
up, including shrinking data
accordingly, or chaining
neural network architecture,
and all sorts of ideas.
You can cook up your ideas for
your favorite architecture,
how to make a large
mini-batch without hurting
the final performance.
But it's still somewhat
of an open question
on how to optimally select how
large your mini-batch should
be.
So even though these
ideas are simple,
you see that every
simple idea leads
to an entire sub area of SGD.
So here are
practical challenges.
People have various heuristics
for solving these challenges.
You can cook up your
own, but it's not
that one idea always works.
So if you look at SGD,
what are the moving parts?
The moving parts in SGD--
the gradients, stochastic
gradient, the step size,
the mini batch.
So how should I
pick step sizes--
very non-trivial problem.
Different deep
learning toolkits may
have different ways of
automating that tuning,
but it's one of
the painful things.
Which mini batch to use?
With replacement,
without replacement
I already showed you.
But which mini batch should I
use, how large that should be?
Again, not an easy
question to answer.
How to compute
stochastic gradients.
Does anybody know how stochastic
gradients are computed
for deep network training?
Anybody know?
There is a very famous algorithm
called back propagation.
That back propagation
algorithm is
used to compute a single
stochastic gradient.
Some people use the word
back prop to mean SGD.
But what back prop really
means is some kind of algorithm
which computes for you a
single stochastic gradient.
And hence this TensorFlow,
et cetera-- these
toolkits-- they come up
with all sorts of ways
to automate the
computation of a gradient.
Because, really,
that's the main thing.
And then other ideas
like gradient clipping,
and momentum, et cetera.
There's a bunch of other ideas.
And the theoretical challenges,
I mentioned to you already--
proving that it works,
that it actually
solves what it set out to do.
Unfortunately, I was too slow.
I couldn't show you the
awesome five-line proof
that I have that SGD
works for neural networks.
And theoretical analysis, as
I said, it's really laggy.
My proof also uses
the with replacement.
And the without
replacement version,
which is the one that
is actually implemented,
there's very little
progress on that.
There is some progress.
There's a bunch of
papers, including
from our colleagues at MIT,
but it's quite unsolved.
And the biggest
question, which most
of the people in
machine learning
are currently excited about
these days is stuff like,
why does SGD work so
well for neural networks?
We use this crappy
optimization method,
it very rapidly
does some fitting--
the data is large,
neural network is large,
and then this neural
network ends up
having great
classification performance.
Why is that happening?
It's called trying to explain--
build a theory of
generalization.
Why does an SGD-trained
neural network
work better than neural
networks train with more
fancy optimization methods?
It's a mystery, and
most of the people
who take interest in
theoretical machine
learning and statistics, that
is one of the mysteries they're
trying to understand.
So I think that's
my story of SGD.
And this is the part we
skipped, but it's OK.
The intuition behind SGD is
much more important in this.
So I think we can close.
PROFESSOR STRANG: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
And maybe I can learn the
proof for Monday's lecture.
PROFESSOR SRA: Exactly.
Yeah, I think so.
That'll be great.